hello everyone and welcome to the Hulu's
bear generation cup knockout phase the
preliminaries are over and now it's time
to check out who will uh proceed to the
semi-finals this is the first
quarterfinal match that we are covering
Magnus Carlsen versus lemon Aryan and
this is game three uh Levon started the
match by winning a game against Magnus
then Magnus retaliated in game two and
this is now game three it's a wild
attacking game where there will be a lot
of attacking but you will not be able to
tell who is actually attacking so let's
dive straight into it the Magnus has the
white pieces and he opens with Knight to
F3 he goes for the reti opening uh Levon
goes D5 we have D4 Knight to F6 and now
a nice C4 transposing um well depending
on what level plays he can play some
like E6 to go into the Queen's Gambit
decline he can go C6 to go for the slav
but he actually just plays the captors
and C4 and he transposed into the
Queen's Gambit accepted so Queen to A4
check by Magnus Knight to C6 here yes uh
C6 is is the more popular about lavongos
for a very concrete idea that is
extremely rare he plays Knight C6 now
Magnus recaptures the pawn and now Pawn
to E5 Levon sacrifices upon
to get some very active play as you'll
see and okay Magnus accepts Knight
captures on E5 with Knight captures D
captors and now Knight the G4 so Magnus
is up a pawn it's a double D Pawn but
still up a pawn and Levon has this
Knight on a very weird Square already on
G4 and now Magnus plays Knight to C3 now
there is a game from the singfield Cup
last year that was played between uh
rihad Rapport and linear Dominguez F4
was played by Rapport in that game ended
in a draw but here Magnus plays Knight
to the C3 and it is now already as of
move 8 that we have a completely new
game so C6 makes sense the takeaway is
some very important squares from this
Knight and now Queen to E4 now just
defending this E5 Pawn because if you
for example instead of C6 if you just
play a knight captures on E5 then uh
this queen to E4 move is very very
annoying just uh challenging this Knight
and there's no good way to handle this
you play Queen E7 to defend United D5
already is coming and now the queen has
to keep an eye on the C7 square and on
the Knight here so that's why
after Knight the C3 it does make sense
to play C6 so Queen to E4 now Magnus
does defend the pawn and the bishop to
C5 nicely attacking the F2 Pawn Magnus
defense Pawn to E3 and now Queen to E7
so still down a pawn but getting some
very very nice development in uh Magnus
pushes F4 uh just uh uh defend d5n in
the future he can use it to further push
with F5 Castles by Lavon and now Bishop
to E2 uh preparing to kick away the
snipe from G4 and also just the castle
with Bishop to B6 and now Magnus castles
and here Lavon says all right I don't
want to face the the marching of those
pawns he pushes Pawn to F5 and this will
pretty much cement these pawns on the
squares as they are also the bishop here
is quite beautiful and he will try to
get his pieces into the attack Bishop to
E6 Rook might come into the game and so
on so here we have Queen to F3 you could
also play e captures an F6 up a song but
it doesn't really make sense to trade
everything off here okay you can trade
Queens captures captures but then comes
Knight captures on E3 and already that
extra Pawn that you had isn't really all
that relevant for example Bishop
captures captures with checking H1
Bishop P6 and now it doesn't really
matter what you play if five Bishop D5
and okay you will still get your extra
Pawn let's say captures captures but
black has a very nice compensation with
the bishop pair and it's um you know
it's a it's a normal game
uh so after F5 Magnus Retreats with the
queen he plays Queen to F3 and now
Bishop to E6 we have Pawn to H3 kicks
away the Knight Knight the H6 and now
Bishop to D2 uh we have G5 by 11 also it
you could play some like rookie to d8
but then just rotate to D1 and nothing
exciting happen solavon sticks to his
plan Pawn to G5 he also has some ideas
of moving the king to each eight and
then just um starting to create some
sort of an attacking battery here on the
G file King H2 Magnus knows that this is
coming so he moves the queen uh the King
right away King to h8 by Lavon and now
Queen to H5 and this is where the game
becomes extremely interesting because
now Magnus is uh threatening to win the
Knight and also to win the G5 phone so
how can you stop this one way to do it
is to play Knight to F7 this defends the
G5 square but it's not very very
exciting for example Rook 8d1 rookie 38
some useful moves will be played and
then E4 and 11. does not have all that
many uh active ideas here he you know
it's a it's a pretty passive position
for him and he does not like this so
instead after Queen to H5 rooked the G8
he just continues with his plan and he
gives up a full piece here so he offers
the queen captures on H6 and other than
this you really uh you know it's hard to
find a better move so Magnus does
capture it even though this means that
he will uh come under a brutal attack so
he has to calculate precisely that he
can defend this so Queen captures an H6
Rook to G6 only Square for magnus's
Queen is the H5 square and now Rook 8 to
G8 now preparing to open up the G file
and play Rook captures on G2 and there
is only one good move here for Magnus
and of course Magnus finds it pawn to G4
idea being that now if you play G
captures on F4 simply e captures an F4
you don't have to worry about the bishop
and you don't have to worry about F
captures on G4 because if Lemon plays
this then F5 and now you will lose even
more material even if G3 check you can
play King to G2 and your position is
perfectly fine Bishop to D5 is
impossible the Knight covers that so
uh you're you're good to go so after G4
Levon says all right Queen to G7 and
this is an extremely extremely
complicated position uh there is only
one way for Magnus to keep his keep his
Edge in this game but he has to find a
very particular idea so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
only move that wins the game for Magnus
while I give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Pawn
to E4 and this creates this very very
weird structure here that is very very
rarely seen I mean try to calculate all
of the pawn captures I dare you it is
impossible but one thing that of course
you can see right away that if uh e
captures on F5 happens we'll attack uh
not that bishop and the rook and of
course if G captures happens also will
attack the bishop and The Rook so how
can Levon uh deal with this it's uh it's
very very hard uh it seems like also
Rook to H6 is impossible because you can
just play Queen captures on G5 you trade
queens and you can no longer uh continue
the attack or even if Rook to G6 then
even you can play this spectacular Queen
captures on F5 that's the point uh now
if Bishop captures an F5 just e captures
an F5 and look at this it it seems like
Levon should be completely winning I
mean Magnus is down a queen but there is
no move you can make the Rook is trapped
all of the squares are covered if you
play Rook to H6 doesn't matter Knight to
E4 and now uh once the Bishops assume
these diagonals there's there's no easy
way to survive this and also the pawns
are just spectacular uh there's nothing
for you for you to do here I mean look
at all of those spawns I mean that that
is worth the queen so uh of course Lavon
doesn't want to do that he plays F
characters and it's interesting if
Magnus
um prepared all this I'm sure he has but
um you know it would be it would be
crazy if he went uh for all of this you
know just an intuition alone so Levon
goes for the uh the other idea which
isn't all that impressive he plays F
characters on G4 he allows F5 and now of
course Rook the H6 this is how he sort
of saves the piece but not really Queen
captures on G4 and now you could play
Queen captures and if I would check but
then if Queen captures an E5 Queen to G3
uh not not much you can do to continue
the attack here so he prepares it Bishop
to C7 next he wants to play Queen
capture Sun uh on E5 and yes if Magnus
captures the bishop here then Queen
captures on E5 is winning for Lavon uh
there's nothing you can do
uh you move the queen uh Queen to H2
will be Checkmate and even if you put
something on F4 to give a little bit
back I just G captures open up opens up
the G file for The Rook you have to move
the queen now Queen captures an E6
attacks the H3 Pawn next you can play
Rook captures on H3 if Queen captures
then even F4 opens up a discovery here
towards the black king uh this is just a
game over but uh yeah you know uh
problem is for the one that Magnus keeps
playing the top engine move every move
and he plays Bishop to E1 now of course
any Queen captures will be met with just
Bishop to G3 so there's really no point
in playing that so Bishop captures an E5
check Bishop to G3 and now Bishop
captures and G3 we have Queen captures
and now G4 finally Levon uh finds a way
to open up the
uh deal to open up the G file and Magnus
says not a problem he could also keep it
closed with H4 but he's not afraid he
says this structure here is impenetrable
so do your best Bishop to C4 bellavon
and now the bishop has to move there's
really no way to keep increasing the
pressure Rook to G1 we have Pawn to B5
now the one has to play something he's
down material but he will of course
continue the uh not the attack but the
game Pawn to E5 now it's not there's no
time to wait of course B4 is coming but
the phones are incredibly scary so
before Knights the E4 and now Bishop to
D5 attacking the Knight but here just
Rook 8 to E1 and he was in this position
unmove 32.1 Levon arunian resigned to
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here Magnus takes uh another win so
even though LeBron won the first game
Magnus won the second and third one and
the fourth one is still being played as
I'm recording this video so I don't know
what will happen there but Levon has to
win on demand the bounds back and now of
course you could continue Butler one had
some 10 seconds on the clock Magnus had
like five minutes and there's really no
good way to play this to give you an
example okay the bishop here isn't all
that useful attacking nothing uh and the
Knight is uh just you know a beautiful
piece here so it makes sense to trade
here let's say captors captures but
again no moves for Lavon if if Queen to
G5 you're gonna push the pawns F6 if
Rook H to G6 now okay you've tripled up
here but F7 if if Rook the Fate Pawn to
E6 and there's just no stopping the
pawns also also some Queen checks are
possible if the queen moves from the
control over D5 Square uh so how do you
stop E7 there's no way to do it you have
to play it and then Queen E5 check just
runs into Rook G7 and let's say Bishop
D1 opens up an attack here next move
you're gonna get checkmated or you can
just start giving up material for
nothing
uh so I have to Rook 81 beautifully
beautifully played by Magnus uh and
Levon but uh like I said Lavon played
the brilliant brilliant sacrifice
brilliant attack but he was um really a
problem for him that uh Magnus just
found all the all the top moves and was
able to was able to defend that position
because it was really a nice sacrifice
really a creative one just opening up
the G file like this but the problem is
the G file never got opened up and maybe
maybe it was the queen sacrifice that
aliban didn't take into consideration
there but uh you know who knows after E4
uh anything is possible yeah but but
this this line is just so beautiful Rook
H6 Queen captures and G5 and after Rook
G6 even Queen captures on F5 I mean look
at this bishop characters e captures
there's no square for this Rook Rook H6
Knights the E4 is coming and I mean uh
if the game went this way oh uh it would
be it would be you know on everyone's um
uh home page you know just uh publishing
it for for everyone to enjoy but this
way Levon played a brilliant sacrifice
Magnus it defended brilliantly and of
course then uh he he just showed that he
he's up that extra piece that alone
sacrificed and there's no point in
continuing the game
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it always be careful when you
sacrifice the piece if you know your
opponent is very very strong at refuting
sacrifices um might not go as great but
uh you know he he had to try something
so yeah I hope you guys enjoyed it very
nicely played by Magnus I would like to
wish a very happy birthday to GoGo and I
would like to thank guia para la Paz
interior Stuart Matthew Derek King and
Brian Paquin for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes and
for those of you who figured it out on
the pause the video moment I actually
gave you a little hint in the quote
above the board see you soon